If saw that med school on to John Locke,
um,
uh, an order major, uh,
scientist and a,
another major founder of political
and social philosophy and theory.
I do again, what I did
with hops, a Vr, again,
do briefly for those who are not
interested in lives and history.
So first I introduce you,
uh,
are a friend today, John Locke, a,
he was born in 1642 in Somerset.
Uh,
his father was a captain
and a parliamentary or army
are kind of small gentry,
uh, uh, math, particularly
ballsy but not poor either.
Uh, uh, in 52, uh, he went to Oxford.
Um, and uh, it was noted, uh, that, uh,
he was idle unhappy and on the
rare mark Qubole in Oxford,
well,
if you do not have a
4.0 at Yale bonds panic,
right? You still can be right. John Law,
there are somebody who blossom later.
He was lead blossom or a,
but he,
by the end he was doing
well. Um, and in fact, uh,
he, uh, uh, became, uh, an, uh,
official, uh, you know, uh,
English universities
called teachers officials,
officers, even at Yale, you know,
we are called officers
of Yale Corporation, uh,
kind of, I think your old
English tradition. Um, anyway,
he was admitted and then in 64,
he gave an address to the college.
And this is a very important
address because this is
when he can learn the views
of younger John Locke and cried
career from this address that in fact,
early in his life he was very
traditionalist and quite authoritarian.
The kings are good and
the people are beasts.
So in a way he was hopsy
and, um, in fact, you know,
in the two tatties he
stays away discussing cops.
But of course the ghost of
hops is all over the place.
Right. Uh, there are actually more
seats in here and that's okay too.
So you don't have to sit on the
steps if you want to. That's fine.
Uh,
uh, a little about the times, uh,
49, I already mentioned
Charles first was executed.
Um, uh, the monarchy was abolished
for that time. Oliver Cromwell,
um, uh, uh, became lord
protector of England.
Uh, um, but, uh,
he was very popular among many.
Uh,
he really could not control the struggle
between the military and the parliament
and the cows. Uh, a hops experienced,
um,
in the 30s and early forties.
In some ways continue with the past,
probably not as bad as before,
but was still very bad.
Belvin Colombo died.
His song tried to become Lord Protector,
did not succeed.
And finally it was decided to
call back Charles First Song,
Charles the second to
become king of England.
So the monarchy was restored.
MMM.
So these were remained turbulent years
and of course the kind of turbulence,
a dusk color of what,
uh, uh, uh,
lock stood for now,
just a picture of Oliver Cromwell for you.
Um,
and then Charles Second,
uh,
who have a skin graft
England for a 25 years.
Um, now that is a new haven
court action to all of this.
And not all of you may know that,
uh,
but I'm sure everybody knows about it.
They really have anu Wales
and that a golf street is now,
this has something to do
with England and John Locke.
Uh,
two of the judges of the
trial of Charles Wong,
Edward Bailey and Villiam Golf,
uh,
we would accused of regicide and they
escaped England in 1660 and they went to
Boston. Uh, now they did their own choice,
right? The event where horror Var this
rather than going very earliest. Okay.
Uh,
but Boston was an unsafe place,
uh,
too much under the control of the crown.
So therefore the went to the right place.
Right. And that can it be, of course,
new haven.
So they came to new haven and you
probably know where West rock is.
Anybody was up on restaurant,
few of them.
Now Invest Doc,
you'll see a sign be tess Josh School.
So if you go that,
that is a little cove and that according
to the legends Vallely and golf high
did in these school. So here you go. Uh,
history comes back home.
Then they moved actually to
Milford and lived in a house there.
And I have the picture of this house.
I don't spare my life on it,
that this is the house in the
day did, but that's what, uh,
uh, some historian, they'll me. Okay.
But that is a turning point in the life
of John Locke in 66 when he meets a
formidable person whose name
was Anthony Ashley Cooper.
Um, bell, he was a high Aristo crat,
but he never, dls was anti royalist. He,
Joe joined the parliamentary
forces against Charles the first,
um, and was also a member
of the State Council, uh,
during the republican times,
but he supported the restoration of
the monarchy in 66 and held very,
very high offices between 60,
60 and 76 three,
including the position of lord chancellor.
Uh,
well, um, uh, he became, uh,
the Earl of Shaftsbury, uh,
out of the grace of the king.
And usually he's referred to as
the Earl of chefs spirit. Uh,
they only in 60, 60 event
to Oxford, um, at Duke, uh,
have a cure for his liver disease.
And this is when he met
John Locke as a doctor.
Um, and, uh, John Locke
became a, his physician.
And let's put it this way,
his friend,
probably a bit of a strong statement
because the social status difference was
too big to really call it as a friendship.
But Ivo say a word
about that relationship.
And here is, uh, um, uh,
the Earl of Shaftsbury, uh,
now, uh, in [inaudible] 67, uh,
lock move to Ashley's house at Exit
Your House in this trend in London.
And I'm sure those of you who visited
London knew exactly that this trend is
that still where sort of the legal
establishment can be found in London.
So he lived there in his household,
like, you know, in feudal times, uh,
clients live to the master's
house and eat on the master stable
or with other servants, stable,
even a high ranking people.
Occasionally we're not a
little to eat right. Uh,
with the Lord.
Now he became Ashley's
confident advisor and surgeon.
He performed a surgery.
And I think medical scientists
are still puzzled, uh,
whether this was some
pathbreaking surgery or vetter.
Uh, he just had good luck,
uh, ad that it helped. Uh, uh,
um, um, Ashley, um,
Ashley had a surplus production of his
liver and he implanted a tube into his
abdomen area to let this surplus flew
out and certainly actually felt much
better after the surgery. Well, uh,
we know that occasionally the doctors
say the surgery was successful and the
patient died. Now this was a
case when the patient was cured,
but we don't know about that. The surgery
had anything to do with it. Right? Uh,
but, uh, uh, for those of
you who are in sciences,
this is just a proof that in
the 17th century, you know,
there was really, I didn't know
distinction yet what sciences are,
what philosophy is and what
the social sciences are,
was a difference,
what theology was and the
rest of the knowledge was.
But the rest of the
knowledge was all the same.
And sort of lock was also a scientist.
67. He wrote an essay,
the essay on toleration,
and this is a departure now from
hops. These actually advocates, uh,
uh, uh, the right to dissent
as we have seen. You know,
not that hops at all costs would
have resisted every descent,
right? You remember we discussed
that that hops also conceited.
If the king does not deliver,
you can't transfer your loyalty from
the king to another stupid fun. But,
uh,
the essay on tolerance does not simply
make it as a such an exceptional case,
you know, uh, but it makes a,
makes a big argument that the right of
the sand is an important individual.
Right?
He was also then elected in [inaudible]
68 as member of the Royal Society.
The royal society is like
what in the United States,
we call the American Academy of Sciences.
Pretty hard to get into
it. Uh, it was then,
and it is now and 79,
and he was already working. And, uh, uh,
the second [inaudible], um, uh, uh,
or assume or lead to some of,
are talking about this,
there is some debate when
the first studies and the
second draft is well written
and that's not irrelevant actually.
The timing of the two essays,
they all, they've also,
uh, on the other hand,
that conflict between Charles the second
and the parliament. And Earl of chefs,
birdie. And of course by
implication, John Locke,
uh, Charles the second had
only illegitimate children.
He had quite a few of them, right? Uh, uh,
I don't know whether he liked children,
but it looks like he liked
the technology at least.
Uh, they are, uh, uh,
therefore, you know, since the
children were all the legitimate,
the legitimate here to the Troon Vasa,
his brother James.
And the only problem with James was that
he was Roman Catholic and we already
know from hops that this was a big
trouble at that time in Britain.
So,
uh,
the parliament and chefs Bertie
himself fear that Roman Catholics will
restaurant that influence and that
for the parliament's role there'll be
reduced. Um, um, and then in 70s, three,
uh, they, uh, the parliament was
considering a Socon test act.
And this is really an ugly act,
right?
Because test act man that you have to
be tested whether you are Roman Catholic
or you belong to the Church of England,
and if you are Roman Catholic,
then you should not hold certain offices.
Right?
This is just still discrimination.
But you know,
at that time it was kind of
defense against the Vatican
and the role of the pool.
Uh, well, uh, um,
uh,
because Shaftsbury support for this,
he was dismissed as lord chancellor.
Nevertheless,
a few years later, uh,
the parliament, uh, uh,
does pass the exclusion bill
and they asked reporting,
uh, James, one of the
illegitimate children, um,
are for chars as a successor to the truth.
Now, um, and this is James Stewart, uh,
the blood or of Charles the second,
and this is the other genes,
the Protestant Shaftsbury sprouter Gee,
well,
the Commons facet of law and Charles,
the second death,
he dismissed the parliament. Uh, uh,
well Shaftsbury was at acid,
a boot into the tower of London.
Uh, you probably, if you've arrived
in London, you visited the tower,
or at least at the look at it,
um,
and after he was released was smarter
than to stay in England who went to a
right place. I actually have like his
stage, the event to the Netherlands. Uh,
if I had to be exiled, I would prefer
it to be in Amsterdam before places.
Uh, okay. Uh, um, uh, in, uh, uh, uh,
83, uh, uh, the Vix,
the vix at that time where the kind of
the Democratic Party by the Tories were
the Republican Party,
right.
And the vix were the equivalent
of the Democratic Party. Well,
the big swirl accused to
have been involved in a plot
to overthrow the king and
some of them we would execute it.
That was the right, right house plot.
There are lock was smart enough,
he knew he may be next in line.
So he also made the right choice.
He van to answer that.
Um, well, again,
I don't swear that this was exactly
the house where the plot took place.
I even not sure if the plot took place
at all or whether this was an invention
by the authorities there.
Then there is that evolution in 88 and
William of orange becomes the king.
Yeah. Uh, um, uh,
well the problem was the gym's a second
did not realize that even the Tories,
VNF support his religious agenda.
So he was actually overthrown.
Um, and, uh, uh, then,
uh, the Republicans and
Democrats, I'm sorry,
the Tories and Vicks came
together and, uh, uh,
they invited William, uh, uh,
to become king of England.
And here it is a very
unstructured and the, uh,
the color, uh, Queen Mary, uh, uh,
uh, uh, his wife, uh,
was very much involved in politics and
important and locked down now can return
to England. Um, and, uh,
he felt safe and, uh, uh, uh, uh,
60 90 to do so. Well, uh, I've,
you've talked about this later.
The second Chatty's May actually be a
reflection of the change to the house of
Orange,
which is a change from absolutism
to constitutional monarchy.
And therefore the second track,
this can be read as an ideology for
a constitutional monarchy rather than
absolute designer, but that this
is the case. It is being debated.
A lock died in 1704.
Interestingly, uh, you know,
he is a major booker and the two
charities on government was published,
uh, um, uh, and, uh, uh, uh,
uh,
60, 90, but, uh,
is it was published anonymously.
You've was concerned enough,
even at that time, uh, that, uh, uh, uh,
he made on in could trouble if
he publishes his book. Okay.
Now I'm here, we'll be talking about
the, the two charities and the,
and the Varick now.
Whoops.
Oh,
of course.
Yes,
Yes.
Okay.
So this is the duties of government,
uh,
reject. Shorty was appeared
in print in a 60, 90,
as you can see on the
first edition. Now, uh,
as I said,
that is a debate about it.
When the first and the second shut
these was written and, uh, uh,
there are two major
locked scholars, uh, uh,
bull spent all of their lives studying
loch beat. The last letter, uh,
suggested that the second Chatty's
was written really first in the 1679.
It was all engaged in the debates
about the exclusion bill a while.
Um, the Chubb Ashcraft to, uh, uh,
he was, my colleague at Ucla at
one point died. Unfortunately,
very young billions scholar.
Uh,
actually he argued that the second
year this was written in 1683.
Um,
and it is an evolutionary work that this
is really the theory of constitutional
monarchy and kind of popular Suva entity
is being formulated for the first time.
This is really in strong crash,
almost absolute negation
of, of hops. Well,
not quite absolute disgust at some
overlaps between the two arguments,
but they both agreed that the first,
that this was written in 1680,
that's on uncontroversial,
um,
and was published anonymously.
So, uh, the first, uh,
tease, uh, um, uh, well,
um, IVL not to speak too
much about this. Uh, uh,
the second that it is really the big text,
uh,
everybody reads and sites. But
the first that these, uh, uh,
takes on a book, uh, published
by 16 and 80 by Robert filmer.
This looks to me,
to me and very arcane book,
but surprisingly it is still in print.
You go on Google and you can
buy a robot filmers, book,
Patriarchy. There. I don't
necessarily recommend it a,
because I think this is really archaic
and I don't think it got any major
contribution beyond challenging lock
to formulate a strong position against.
That's, I think the only reason why
you may want to read patriarchy.
Now.
Uh,
he was very much for absolutism
and the absolute monarchy,
and he advocated actually inequality.
He said,
God said some man above others
and he meant men, right?
Men are set over women,
right? Uh, and, uh,
older people like me are set over
younger people like you, right?
And the king over everybody else,
right?
So this inequality of
power is coming from God.
God decided that Aiden inherits the earth.
And then the sentence of Aden,
the sons and grandsons received
their share of earth's right.
So you'll have to show your family tree.
Going back to Adam who
received the, the, uh, uh, uh,
word as a grant,
and who was the first king?
So the king should trace their
family trees back, right?
To the first person of grace of God.
All right?
So there was a scripture argument that
God vested Paternal Authority in Aden,
uh, gave the earth as a grant to him. Um,
and the monarchical absolute
power is inherited this way.
That is the scent of the
monarchy go power. So I said,
I see very little right
relevance of this argument.
Uh, so I, I,
but certainly it was important
for luck to have a astrue man,
right? He could fees his
argument against, um,
uh, probably spent too
much time, right? Um,
debating filmer.
And you may have been a bit concerned
about this theological controversies and
theological arguments in the
book, but otherwise, you know,
he's really formulating the first big
ideas for modern democratic theory.
Okay. So, uh, uh, now Lark as,
uh, engages, uh, uh, filmer, uh,
on a number of level,
um,
it actually engages him on the
theological level and he said, well,
it's Anshu, uh, that Aiden,
uh, received the land.
There's grant,
it was mankind who received the,
the land is a grant from God
and then he moves on and he,
uh,
kind of, uh, makes, uh,
a more technical argument
is that they are,
even if we assume that it was one single
male who the of land and all authority,
uh, how a nurse, you can trace
your yourself back to this.
This is not a real good
way to legitimate somebody.
How can Charles the second
shows, that's, you know,
he has the answers to the survey now,
so that is not the right way
to do. And then he said, well,
even if it could be done, it
would be silly to do that, right?
Just because somebody is the
proper ancestor should not have,
should not be this juvenile. What
if that person is a jerk? Right?
Then you really want to have the right
people, right to exercise authority,
right? It's a right in his Stan, you know,
a very daring argument.
Now let's have a look at the second
Chatty's and the major themes.
What he's like, like, uh,
uh, engaging. Why cops,
he begins with the statement,
we are all born equal and he has free,
free and equal.
But as we voc he throws a very
different conclusion than hops,
dead or by and large,
different conclusion.
And then here does equity.
The clock that we need,
um, uh, uh, common
superior, uh, uh, a silver,
silver and a superior is
necessary to avoid, uh,
the state of war.
Then he develops a fascinating theory
of property, what we have to deal with.
Uh,
and then he makes these
pathbreaking aren't humans,
um, that, uh, uh, what we
need is a rule by majority.
He does not quite identify what
that, that majority is, right?
This is not popular sue veracity yet.
But the idea of rule by majority for the
first time is formulated by John Locke.
And acceptance of authority can be done
only by consent and what is needed.
And this is the very
big contribution of law,
a separation of powers,
checks and balances, right?
This is what is completely
missing in hops.
And he's making these past
breaking, um, uh, argue man.
So yeah,
are all born free and equal.
Let me speak to this a level now.
What is political power?
And he defies these three elements
of political power, right?
Well, uh, this is, uh,
uh, the right to make law
that is also execution of law.
And that is also politics means the
defense of the common vast against outside
enemies that are these
three functions, right? Uh,
politics is serving and this will be very
important in his sort of divisions of
powers as such. Now, ah,
Bell, if he want to understand
their political power,
political power is we have to see at the
origins of political power and to try
to understand why owners,
people from the state of nature,
where they were free and the claw move
into civil society where these two
rounder,
some of their freedom and veal Vivia
CVL surrender some of that equality.
So, uh, what is the origins of this, uh,
uh,
equality bell?
The first argument is very
much counter hops, right?
Men all well at all made
by God the omnipotence,
right?
And we are his rapper.
The account of theological
argument and the are not,
have not been created for
the pleasures of one another.
So there should not be any men who is
a superior, right? But then support.
All right, because we are free,
right? The lock is a liberal,
right?
Hearts is a conservative.
So what we are experiencing now,
right,
is the transition of philosophy
wrong conservativism to liberalism,
right? And liberalism, of
course we'll emphasize,
but particularly freedom
is the primary, uh, uh,
uh, value. Uh,
and in the state of nature,
he said,
we will all governed by reason and I eh,
and that actually sort of
because we are all reasonable,
the are born the reasonable you
are born to be able to be rational,
right?
They should be able right to understand
that they are not supposed to harm each
other is it is a very different
arguments. But what we have seen, uh,
uh, uh, on from hops on Tuesday, right?
A hops said that we are
actually learning more reality,
uh,
out by interacting with others
who are desiring the same stuff.
What we do, we are learning
it from struggle, right?
He does not assume that this
comes out of our rationality.
That we are reasonable and by nature good.
He does assume that we are reasonable.
Therefore why owners be should not
know that we should respect others.
Well,
Bot and this then is where law comes
the closest to converge with the hops.
Well that is on the other hand,
a danger that that ear will be have
a war and in order to avoid war,
this is why the real subject
ourselves to an authority.
And leave the state of nature.
Uh,
uh,
but he also makes a claim just
to distance himself from harps.
He said, that's not, that's the state
of nature is necesarrily war. Right?
They have to make a distinction between
the state of war and state of nature.
We've got no state of nature of are
good and reasonable, but nevertheless,
uh, it, uh,
it can turn into a state of war and
that's why we will have to join civil
society, um, and accept and authority.
Well,
and now comes again a very big difference.
So he accepts the danger of war.
He lived in times of war and he accepts
that we need an authority because,
um, after this, uh, now, um, but, and,
and now you come to the
big differences. Well, uh,
the live, uh, we, we
subject ourselves to, uh,
authority, uh, of others,
but this has to be,
has to be done by consent, right? Uh,
those who are,
who are accepting a server and have to
consent to the subjugation to authority.
Uh, and the last citation
is also extremely important,
right?
Freedom of men on their government is
to have a standing rule of liberty,
right?
Come on to every one of that society and
made by a legislative power erected in
it, right? So the legislative power,
now this is the source of [inaudible]
is somehow in a proper way constituted,
right?
This was not a problem really for a hops.
Not much,
right?
He could see that that will be simply
confirming a silver entity to a single
king.
Now lock is very interested how the
silver and the source of power to pass
legislation is being constituted.
And again,
he's emphasizing which was
not in hops but is important.
The standing rules to assure liberty,
right?
Not simply survival,
Davino hopes had it a more complex way,
but liberties the major issue.
Uh,
but we are seeking for now
and then he comes to it,
an interesting guy.
The or why do we submit ourselves to
authority and seek protections for our
liberty because we want
to protect our property.
That's the role of the public
authority to Platek covered the,
it's a very realistic and the important
assumption aggression and which he and
Karl Marx would probably agree.
What is that all of the governments
do guarantee the sacredness of private
property.
And he has an interesting ideas about
what property is that it is coming from.
Very important.
This foreshadows Adam Smith's in some
days also foreshadows Karl Marx in another
day.
Now he starts with this idea that men
had given the word two men in common,
and therefore all the fruits belong
to each member of the society.
It's almost trite a socialist
ideology, right? Um,
uh, and, uh, he continues
along these lines.
He said every man has a
property in his own person,
right? And, uh,
the label of what you produce is yours,
right?
The productive you labor belongs to you.
And you will see this is
the first formulation,
what we bill learn from Adam Smith and
Karl Marx as the Labor theory of value,
right? Libor belongs to
the Labor, right? Um,
uh, as, as such, uh, uh,
because it was created by what is yours,
the only thing,
what certainly is yours, and this
is new. We're on body, right?
And you labor in capacity.
He's had an for this labor being the
unconventional property of the Labor.
Uh, and then this is a beautiful
citation. I just love it, right?
Uh,
do the water running in the fountain
be every once yet who can doubt?
But that in the picture is
his only who do with that.
Bingo. Right? How crisp
Billy in once sentence,
right?
He can capture these wonderful
idea that libor creates the value,
right? Wonderfully done. And of course,
great influence on Adam
Smith and Karl Marx
there, but there are also limits
on private property. Again, he,
he almost reads like a socialist.
Uh,
he said may anyone and gross
as much as CVL a dovish,
shy answer, not soul, right?
God has given us all things richly
hell, but how far has he given
it to us to enjoy, right?
And whatever is beyond this is more
than your share. You have only,
uh, in your, uh, belongs to you.
What you can actually enjoy nothing,
but you accumulate these radical idea.
If your back paddle in a minute,
right?
I'd be show you how he backed
out of this very radical idea.
But, um, uh, um,
now I,
and the chief Macha is of course ers,
he said it's absolutely obvious right
at the property belongs to those who can
cultivate it,
right?
As much land as mental plants improves,
cultivates and can use the production
of so much. This is Blah burpee.
So the land belongs, it's not another
notion of private ownership of the land.
It's an ownership by the cultivator.
And also,
let me just point out why running
out of time there is a very important
difference here, right? But essential
for four look argument is the abundance.
He can make this argument because the
primary assumption is that what we desire
is available in great abundance to us.
We have seen that hops had
the opposite idea, right? Uh,
we are fighting each other because what
we actually desire is a scarce good,
too many people want and then we
kill each other to get it right.
So that is a scarcity assumption in hops.
And there's an abundancy a hypothesis in,
in lock and you have to make up your
mind who is appealing to you more. Uh,
do you think that the scarcity assumption
is a better one or the abundancy
argument is an empirical
and more dealing one?
Well, and then he, as I said, now he back
backpedals he knows he's going too far.
He said Bud Brigade, remember God
gave the word to man in common,
but since she gave them for
the benefit, uh, well, uh,
he basically did it to
the industrials once.
So those who are very hard there
shouldn't get more rather than who does do
notary that hard.
And then he actually will go,
um, uh, uh, further, um,
labor creates value.
Right.
And the argument is right that everything,
uh,
what has been created as a
value has been created by a,
or almost everything. That's
interesting kind of equation at the end.
Uh, right. Um,
the products of the earth's
used food to life of man,
he said nine tenths are
the effects of labor. Well,
I don't know if we felt that be
it certainly about, well what,
what that really means and why or nurse,
she makes a claim.
But now and here comes a
very big qualification.
The invention of money at cumulation
of property becomes possible,
right? And therefore, as a
accumulation of money occurs, uh,
well,
uh,
then wells can be hoarded up
the south injury to any wall.
And this becomes, again, very
important, right? For liberal theory,
you can't do anything by which you
do not injure somebody else, right?
But shouldn't be prohibited.
And where government should send in when
they sense injury against somebody else.
Right
now,
in order to preserve property,
you will have to transfer power to
the community, to civil society.
There are some very important arguments
here. It has to be by settling.
Standing rules has to be written down,
has to be agreed upon,
and it has to be permanency.
There must be a permanent
suppose goes through.
You need a predictable environment,
uh,
and it has to be the same to all parties.
You cannot make a law,
which applies to the surface and the law,
which applies to the noble man.
It has to be the same law
for everyone. Um, uh, uh, uh,
such, uh, well, um,
and this is the origin of a legislative
and executive power of civil societies.
Well, uh, there is a difference
between, uh, uh, absolute manner.
He, uh, and constitutional monarchies.
He said in an absolute monarchy,
you can appeal to the law, uh,
to restrain violence against you
by another subject of the crown.
But he said in an absolute monarchy,
you cannot really appeal against the king.
That's what, you know, in
communist societies, you
could not sue the government,
right? Even in Stalinist Russia,
you could saw your neighbor,
if your neighbor did school
steal something from you.
But if the government is
steer anything from you,
you could not sue the Soviet government,
right?
But a democratic system means
this is foreshadowed here.
If you can sue the government,
right.
And of course in the United States
they can sue the government. Well,
you can try it. We are not
over. It's very, but, uh,
good luck avail.
Um,
and then he says, this is
fun and very, very good.
Well,
the thing that men are so foolish that
they care to avoid plus miss chiefs can
be done to them like your
neighbor polecats or focuses,
but our counter not to think of the
safety of divorce by lions as crazy lions
are the kinks, right? The big authorities.
So don't just seek,
um,
laws which protect you against
your neighbor. See Clause,
which protects you against those in
position of authority and power. Uh,
right. Uh, and that not we would
be no civil society unless,
uh, uh, this, uh, uh, bands, well,
he advocates than the principle
of rule by the majority, right?
Uh,
well what we need,
I can't sent of every individual who
made the community in order to create
legitimate through, um,
uh, and once these, uh,
is, uh, uh, arrived at
and that you're bound, um,
everybody,
uh, uh, uh,
and the bond can be subjected
to authority only by consent.
They are, this concept can be passive
is not necessarily all of us. Uh,
explicit. You are born in the
United States. You did not approve,
right? The constitution of
the United States, never.
The less you have to obey the
constitution of the United States,
you have one chance not to do so.
Uh,
you can move through Afghanistan
if that's what you prefer, right?
So you don't have to go by American law.
You can live under Islamic law.
Then you move to a country,
the world by Islamic law.
Uh,
and then the final major contribution,
the separation of powers.
And he makes a distinction between
three types of powers, legislative,
executive,
and federative powers.
That's very different from Montesquieu
and different from the American
constitution right there. The three
branches are legislative, executive,
and judicial power. Uh,
he makes that claim, uh,
that the turn branches federative power.
Federative power is a defense
against outside enemies. And he said,
look, but it's important that legislative
power and executive power has to be
separated from each other.
Uh,
it is absolutely as if it is the same
person or the same authority which passes
the law and which also executes the law.
We have to separate those. Um, uh, and,
uh,
oh,
val, I don't have time to go
into this. Uh, uh, uh, uh,
it's clearly enough. Uh, and then
that is the kind of federative powers.
As far as the federative powers
are concerned. He said, well,
the federative powers may not be
necesarrily separated from the executive
branch.
It can be actually held by
the executive branch as such,
as in many ways,
it is the key.
It's very unclear in the United States
who actually has this federative powers,
right? By law, it is the congress,
which can declare only laws, uh,
wars.
But as we have seen,
the United States was engaged in a
number of major military actions,
but commonly we call wars,
though the war was never declared right.
And it was the executive branch,
right,
which they fuck to a declared
war and conducts war.
Uh, occasionally we saw the consent
occasionally against right. Um,
the, uh, Bill, uh, of the, uh, uh,
of the house and the Senate.
So it's a complex issue,
but I think he was quite
right that, uh, uh, often, um,
the federal active power and
executive power are the same.